it's not just about where you're from
it's about the changes that you are very
adamant about making from the places you
grew up in uh you're very serious about
your culture you're very serious about
uplifting and creating opportunities for
your people
um especially in a place that you come
from right I want to see change here was
that a thing that was always there the I
want to see change here was the thing
that was always there for me initially
because I didn't know any better it came
from in front of the camera it came from
like the images that I wanted to see
just because I had I had seen them I had
grown up on them so I knew it was
possible and so then when it was taken
away when I was watching TV in like high
school and college movies I was like
where's all this stuff that I grew up on
like you know where are these stories
and why is it just kind of the same
narrative that's being shown I know
we're more than this and so like even
creating was born out of a frustration
and then when I did that online and
started making the content I was like oh
there are all these other jobs and
initially it just came out from my
circle yeah these are the people I know
and so they're helping me to make this
they happen to be black because most of
my friends are black and then you know
then by extension we were bringing on
you know more diverse crew and then then
it wasn't until I would work on for
smaller things other sets and I'd be
like damn this is like
I didn't realize how rare this is to
work with other people of color like
Hollywood is very very white behind the
camera and so then it became like well
if I get my own show like I still want
to replicate this because
I see that it's a rarity and why not
because I can how did you figure it out
how did you figure out the the
development space of awkward black girl
right like you said you came up you
wanted to act you knew that's what you
wanted to do but
um a lot of people struggle with well
what's my entry you were a hot commodity
just in the next version of a thing this
girl is a star like oh my God you gotta
watch this girl like creating that and
then developing that like where did that
understanding come from was that college
that gave you that knowledge yeah a
little bit I mean not for myself in
particular but like people don't know
that Aqua black girl was like the third
web series that I made it was the third
attempt and it's the only one that I was
in the first two that I made you know I
wrote and directed them editing them all
those things you know that you're doing
when you're making online content
yourself
and you know the first one I did do in
college and that was starring my friends
and I love the response that that guy
just from college to college and you
know it was about being black at
Stanford called dorm Diaries and that
was like oh okay I made something that
people like and it's spreading beyond my
friend group this is dope and I just
made it online
and then I still wanted to sell it to TV
so I was trying to like reach into my
network to be like hey I made this show
people really like it online it's only
like 500 to 1000 people but you know
it's it's something and they didn't want
it so then I created my second show
after that and it was starring my
brother and his friend group and that
was something I took more seriously
online where I was like I'm gonna
release it every week and build a
following there and I started to learn
the tools of like you know you can't
make contact that's too long online you
have to catch people's attention you
have to build it you have to be
consistent so I started developing those
skills so by by the time I did Awkward
Black Girl
and put myself in it even though I was
scared as hell to put myself in wow well
why why didn't you put yourself in the
other ones well I by that time I was
just like I like to write and direct
because I had gone to a school that um
that you know like the plays and stuff
where I'd have been I went to a
predominantly black and Latino high
school so like the plays were for us I
was in all of those well by the time I
got to college it was predominantly
white college like there were no roles
they were making stuff for us so I had
no interest in the same way and so it
came like my directing and writing came
from like oh I'm gonna make it I will
create like a play that features us or
whatever it is so by the time awkward
black girl came around I didn't want to
feature my stuff because I didn't have
the same confidence anymore I've been
working with actors and
also you know I had someone else in mind
like I wrote it with somebody else in
mind and then that person couldn't do it
because she was in law school I was in
LA she was in DC and so I just felt like
I was running out of time so I was like
yeah